[Musica]
eccomi
questo è il kurdistan corti stanno
letteralmente significa la terra dei
culti è una regione che si trova tra
l'iran l'iraq la siria alla turchia e
l'armenia
sono circa 35 milioni di persone che
dopo la prima guerra mondiale gli
alleati occidentali decidono di non
mantenere la promessa fatta tolgono lo
stato kurdistan e questo popolo si trova
tra queste nazioni perseguitato ormai
per cento anni io provengo da una
famiglia molto grande e del kurdistan
dalla famiglia del clan del popolo
falchera show sono molto orgogliosa
della mia famiglia in primis perché
questa famiglia è riconosciuta in tutto
il kurdistan e in secondo luogo perché
questa famiglia alti profili
intellettuali che hanno lottato per il
riconoscimento dell'identità del popolo
corto beh sicuramente posso dire che
l'identità ha diversi aspetti per me per
poter costruire la propria identità vi
racconto un piccolo aneddoto mio
personale proprio della mia famiglia io
ho iniziato a studiare in svezia e
quando sono andata in svezia
i miei genitori come tutti i genitori
immagino andavano trovare i propri figli
ei miei venivano a trovare me mio padre
una delle visite che ha fatto
nell'ultima sera mi disse fidia mia via
in un attimo sediamoci qua e prese un
foglio e una penna e scrisse sul foglio
un numero 116 tuo asas nel mondo non
esiste nessuno come te né fisicamente né
biologicamente non c'è nessuno che ti
può assorbire per cui ricordati che te
sei unica nel mondo
questo non te lo devi mai dimenticare ma
se io a questa sull aggiungessi 10 e
questa 0 rappresentasse assalti si
autodetermina come donna all'interno
della società asa non è più lunga
1 mazzarri è diventata 10 e se questo 10
questa schalke è ormai come donne out
the terminal pensasse di poter costruire
una società una collettività un
benessere per collettività diventerebbe
cento
e se questa sull decidesse di creare la
propria carriera nella difesa delle
minoranze nella difesa delle donne con
l'asal diventerebbe mille e se in più
questa sull decidesse di crearsi una
famiglia delle persone coscienti per la
società
questa salti di interesse 10.000 è così
aggiungerei tanti altri zeri per
arrivare a un milione per descrivere
quella sa che è diventato un milione ma
se io asal metto la mano su quel numero
uno vedo tanti zeri
se non ci sei tu asal non c'è nulla
tutto quello che è stato costruito è un
assoluto nulla per cui figlia mia
devi ricordare che la tua identità e
fondamentale all'interno della società e
per costruire una buona società bisogna
avere degli esseri umani che riconoscono
la propria identità
ecco forse è una parte della mia
identità è quella dell'essere donna
perché poter distruggere il sistema
patriarcale poter riconoscere
ricostruire la propria identità come
donna all'interno della società è molto
difficile ed è ancora più difficile in
medio oriente
le mie compagne dell'unità di difesa
delle donne che nel nord est della siria
hanno combattuto contro lo stato
islamico e vi faccio vedere alcune di
queste compagnie satine fidan lei la
guardate qua siamo nell'accademia delle
donne della ricostruzione della nostra
identità e guardate qua lei l'ha uccisa
per mano del regime turco equa ceylan
la prima donna curda che parlò di un
autodeterminazione delle donne è qua che
green calaf nel nord est della siria
uccisa per mano dei jihadisti turchi
perché parlava di una siria libera di
una siria democratica e qua a ritmi fan
tutti noi ce lo ricordiamo ha ri presa
dai jihadisti dell'isis nella città di
cova nei si fece esplodere pur di non
finire nelle loro mani ecco queste donne
di che cosa parlano
queste donne parlano di una società
democratica che si basa di una
democrazia dal basso
queste donne parlano di una
partecipazione diretta nelle politiche
della società non delle quote non di una
scelta della libertà che parla dove
sposarsi con chi sposarsi no produrre
pensieri liberi senza essere
condizionati dal nulla né dalla cultura
né dalla religione né dallo stato come
donna autodeterminarsi e provare a
costruire una società che parla di
ecologia
queste sono le mie compagne che nel nord
est della siria si sono auto determinati
beh un'altra parte della mia identità e
quella curda proprio del gruppo etnico e
io per poter parlare del gruppo etnico
devo parlare di accusare già line rider
del popolo curdo leader del partito dei
lavoratori del kurdistan che a tutto il
mondo ha riferito che c'è un popolo che
si chiama il popolo curdo che e represso
che cerca la democrazia
lui grazie a lui e grazie a tutte le
persone che con noi hanno deciso di
ribellarsi contro i regimi dove vivevano
si è venuta a scoprire che c'è un popolo
che è repressa
beh l'altro aspetto della mia identità
probabilmente è legata al fatto che sono
migranti
io sono migrante in italia e penso che
essere emigrante mi abbia permesso in
italia di riconoscermi totalmente come
internazionalista io non riesco a vedere
né barriere né confini per gli esseri
umani
se le merci possono circolare nel mondo
vuol dire che gli esseri umani possono
circolare e credo che nel mondo nessuno
è straniero perché la patria degli
esseri umani nel mondo intero
ecco da qui penso che l'identità delle
persone non è collettiva non è
totalizzante ma è soggettiva che va
costruita io vorrei una società che
parlasse di miliardi di di vendita con
il ricordo del fatto che l'identità è
fondamentale e la memoria che noi
abbiamo conquistato non è scontata
grazie mille
[Musica]